Success.
The Ai beat me.
Hello world it Saroj and just a few days
ago opened a eyes team of bots won a
match against a team of some of
the best dota players in the world.
I'll explain how they did it in
this video and if you're new here,
hit the subscribe button to stay
up to date on my latest AI content.
The event was streamed online to over
a hundred thousand people and it was
massive.
I was there in the thick of it amongst
the crowd and could feel the energy all
around me. I even got to say hi to Andre
Carpathia, which was algorithmic. Yes,
I'm starting that.
This is a big deal.
The entire AI community is
very excited about the results.
Open AI calls their algorithm five
because it's a set of five neural networks
that work together to
defeat the opposing team.
Open Ai Five has now played
against several opposing teams.
Although it started off playing
against open AI employees.
It moved onto audience members,
valve employees,
an amateur team, a Semipro
team, and now this,
the reason open AI is dedicating all of
their time and energy to creating bots
that can beat humans at Games is because
the idea that if an AI can learn how to
navigate and strategize
in an unstructured, messy,
unpredictable environment
like a game world,
we can transfer all of those skills that
it's learned onto complex real world
problems like drug discovery,
materials design, climate change,
and ASM.
Our videos when IBM's deep blue beat the
world champion Garry Kasparov at chess
in the 90s it surprised a lot of people
and the algorithms it used including
tree search.
Many macs and Alpha Beta pruning proved
to be useful in other applications like
route planning for vehicles.
Just last year,
a similar victory occurred when Google's
Alphago bought beat the best go player
in the world go has a search space that's
orders of magnitude larger than chess
and many wrongly predicted that it
wouldn't be possible for an AI to defeat a
human so soon.
Now with open AI,
five Dota or defense of the ancients
too is the newest game to be conquered.
Dota two is an online multiplayer game
where two teams consisting of five
players each compete to collectively
destroy a large structure defended by the
opposing team called the ancient
while defending their own.
It's a real time strategy game and
it's presented on a single map.
From a three dimensional perspective.
The game has 115 playable characters
that players can choose from.
Each has its own design,
strength and weaknesses.
Once the game begins,
players start off with an experience
level of one with just one ability but are
able to level up and become more
powerful during the course of the game.
Up to a maximum level of 25
abilities are gradually unlocked.
In 2011 the creators of Dota Valve
sponsored 16 teams to compete at the
international,
uh,
Dota specific sports tournament
for $1 million prize. Since then,
it's become an annual championship
tournament with the prize money increasing
each year.
In total,
Dota two tournaments have earned teams
over $100 million in prize money up to
now making it the highest earning
east sports game of all time.
Brb switching careers players dedicate
real time and effort to become
professionals at this game,
which makes open Ai's win
that much more impressive.
Open AI five consists
of five neural networks.
Each neural network is a single layer,
10 24 units,
long short term memory,
recurrent network recurrent networks
specialize in sequence learning.
Give it a sequence of words and it'll
predict the next word in that sequence.
Unless the input data is too big,
if there are too many words,
the recurrent network will start to forget
what it learned from the first words.
A variance of recurrent networks.
LSTM networks account for this problem
popularly known as the vanishing gradient
problem by adding a clever combination
of operations and variables to the
network such that during the gradient
descent process where the gradient value
is what we use to update the weights
of the network accordingly during every
training iteration doesn't vanish.
It's maintained throughout the network.
It's locked into the weights of the
LSTM network components called gates.
Accordingly,
and since the gates are differentiable,
the cell learns what's
important to remember and
what's important to forget over
time.
During optimization,
each open AI single layer LSTM network
receives the current Dota two games
states as its input,
which is extracted from Valves Bot Api.
This contains all the relevant data about
where players are and what's happening
on the map inside of a vector.
The output of each LSTM is
an action on what to do next.
There are several possible action heads
and the LSTM chooses the specific action
path to take, then executes it in
a supervised learning scenario.
It's all about learning the input slash
label relationships so that given new
data it can label it properly.
But unfortunately there's no static
data set here. Sorry, Kaggle.
It's a real time environment and the
signal is not an immediate label,
but instead a time delayed
label called the reward.
This is instead of paradigm
called reinforcement learning.
The reward is provided by the environment
itself and specified by the creator of
the environment.
Open Ai developed a reward that
consisted of a combination of aggregated
metrics, including net
worth, kills and assists.
These rewards can either be positive
or negative depending on what the agent
does in the environment.
The agent receives the state of the
game as input takes an action in the
environment and either receives a
positive or negative reward signal,
which it uses to update its weights to
select an action more likely to receive
her award.
Every training iteration.
The agent in this case is
an LSTM neural network,
and we can frame the way it has to make
decisions as what's called a Markov
decision process.
There's a set of possible game
states of possible actions,
a reward function,
and a description of each
actions affects in each state.
The reason it's called Markov is because
it'll have the mark coff property,
which states that the effects of an action
taken in a given state depend only on
that state and not on the prior history.
Although the dynamics of the environment
are outside of the agent's control,
it will through the training process,
develop what's called a policy.
A policy is defined as the probability
distribution of actions given a state.
It can use this policy to decide what
the next best action to take would be.
The objective of any reinforcement
learning agent is to maximize the expected
reward when following a policy.
To learn this policy,
lots of algorithms exist.
One popular algorithm is
called policy gradients.
The idea is that when an agent
takes an action in an environment,
it might receive a positive reward,
but what if that action is
actually bad in the long run?
What if we could wait and see how this
action played out until someone wins the
game?
The PG algorithm helps learn a policy
that samples actions and then the actions
that happened to eventually lead to good
outcomes get encouraged in the future.
The actions taken that lead to
bad outcomes get discouraged,
seems legit.
Each action has an advantage estimate.
It numerically answers the question of
how much better is this action than the
average or expected action
I take at this state.
The gradients that are computed during
optimization are accumulated over a
number of full played episodes,
then applied to the network,
but it turns out there's a problem
with policy gradient methods.
They're very sensitive to the choice of
step size during the training process.
If a step is too small, then the
progress is small and if it's too large,
the response will be noisy.
Making it very challenging in
a policy gradients setting.
If the agent ends up in a
poor region of action space,
it can leave it in a position where it
has very few useful state action pairs to
learn from.
For example,
if an agent tries to navigate a maze to
find some cheese and had accidentally
learned a policy of just
spinning in circles,
it would have a hard time reaching any
actions that had a positive reward.
Since it could only learn to
increase an action probability.
By experiencing that action and
seeing that it leads forward,
it literally gets stuck and its
own learned loop with no way out.
How can we make an update
that's guaranteed to improve
our current policy or at
least not make it worst God mode?
Of course. Just kidding. Well,
if we separate our
policy into two policies,
a post update policy called the new
policy and a pre update policy called the
old policy,
we can calculate this at each state.
We take a sum over the actions of the
new policy probability at that state
multiplied by how much better that action
is than the average old policy action
at that state termed the advantage.
We then weigh each state's expected
new policy advantage by how likely that
state is to be reached by the new policy.
This gets us the expected
advantage of the new policy.
Over the old one and lets us confirmed
that expected advantage is positive
before we take a move.
The approach of the trust region policy
optimization algorithm or t RPO is to
calculate an estimate of the advantage
quantity we've just described,
but doing so using the distribution of
states from the old policy rather than
the state distribution
from the new policy.
It controls the rate of policy change
by placing a constraint on the average
difference or KL divergence between the
new and old policy after each update.
Even still trp Oh,
has a very poor sample efficiency,
usually taking a large number of training
steps to optimize open AI introduced
their own spinoff of Trp
Rpo called proximal policy
optimization and that's the
algorithm they used for their bots.
It simplifies the problem by converting
trp Rpos KL divergence from a constraint
into a penalty term with no need
to compute the KL divergence.
The Algorithm is less complex.
It strikes a balance between
ease of implementation,
sample complexity and ease of tuning.
So Open Ai,
trained by LSTM networks using PPO on
two 56 gps available on Google cloud,
flying 180 years worth of games against
itself every day from walking to skill
development,
to learning coordination.
There are bots improved
throughout the process.
The next step for the team is to move
on to the international and play against
the best in the world.
If you want to learn more about any
of the topics I've talked about,
check out the links in
the video description.
All your policy are belong to us.
Hit subscribe.
If Ai excites you too, and make sure to
connect with me on Instagram, Facebook,
and Twitter. For now, I've got to play
with some data, so thanks for watching.